estos dos cuadriláteros los
cuadriláteros f g h y el abc t estos son
semejantes si después de alguna
combinación de traslación es rotaciones
reflexiones o dilataciones puedo hacer
que uno quede encima del otro y la
semejanza nos permite utilizar
dilataciones que esencialmente significa
escalar una de las figuras tanto hacia
arriba como hacia abajo si habláramos de
congruencia entonces no estaríamos
escalando las figuras sólo estaríamos
trasladando rotando o reflejando
pero veamos si podemos hacerlo así que
primero vamos a trasladar lo traslademos
esta figura primero pongamos este punto
arriba de este punto y ahora vamos a
rotarlo y lo vamos a rotar alrededor del
punto de aquí para que quede justo ahí
ahora tengo dos de los lados que parecen
coincidir y ahora déjamelo dilató hacia
abajo déjame escalarlo hacia abajo
entonces esto es déjame lo pongo en
donde quiero en donde quiero no
cambiarlo y déjame ver si puedo escalar
esto hacia abajo y si pude hacerlo así
que con puras traslación es rotaciones y
ni siquiera tuve que utilizar
reflexiones traslación es rotaciones y
dilataciones puede hacer que éstos
coincidieran
por lo que estas dos figuras estas dos
figuras son semejantes por lo que si los
rectángulos son semejantes hagamos uno
más así que estos dos triángulos y solo
viéndolos a simple vista este de aquí se
ve mucho más alto que este de aquí por
lo que no parecen semejantes pero déjame
al menos déjame tratar al menos
déjame trasladarlo déjame hacer este
punto el punto ce puede corresponder al
punto f aunque ahora se ve bastante
claro que no lo hará por lo que ahora
déjame dilatarlo
déjame dejar este punto en dónde está y
déjame intentar escalar esto hacia
arriba y luego vemos bastante claro que
hicimos que el segmento cde coincidiera
después de escalarlo hacia arriba que
coincidiera con el segmento efe pero
luego todo lo demás no está empatando
el punto de está en un lugar muy
diferente del punto a una vez que
intente escalar las cosas hacia arriba
un poco así que estos dos triángulos
claramente claramente no son semejantes